greetings you bad [__] uncle
Joey here Monday October 3rd
it's a beautiful [__] night to be in
action it's a great [__] day thank
you for joining us on the pre Church
periscope going deep tonight we're going
deeper than deep tonight we haven't seen
you [__] we have a lot to talk
about but it's one of those [__]
nights so strap a pair on when you [__]
them we kick up with Black Sabbath Black
Sabbath you know it's gonna be [__] a
bad mother [__] night bomb hits
Gorilla Biscuits explosives whatever you
need we got you follow me
[Music]
if you ain't doing fungus like that
you're slippin [__] myself and my
[__] rosh hashanah co-host it's a
beautiful day for [__] Jewish people
today it's a new year put the challah
bill in your pocket and rub both your
hands so every day in mm up in 1617 you
got a yardstick in your pocket
tomorrow we're picking up the [__]
listen but shipment of stars listen if
we dump it in the ocean every fish would
[__] die but tonight we're going
deeper than deep these [__] things
made with [__] hash or and my sugar
the juice and [__] Puerto Rican
toenails this [__] will [__] kill you
listen and 200 milligrams apiece we're
gonna eat for tonight 400 milligrams
just to start off the [__] at night why
because I haven't seen you I'm happy to
[__] see you I gotta take care of my
vertigo I keep spinning I figured what
the [__] he's 400 milligrams of THC and
there's some comment the [__] down you
understand me does chosen one
[Music]
that's right now are you [__] nuts or
little eat more pieces let me show you
how to stop let me show you how these
come just so you know [__]
these things will kill you I'm telling
you right now they come it's 200
milligrams and they come for little
[__] cubicles like this look at this
look but see it's for little pieces
these [__] are stuck together
ain't been nothin in the Sun that's when
you get really [__] up the power of
Christ compels you [__]
oh yeah regurgitate already issue I've
never done this much of the speedball
sounds like one of the squares just
everyone knows
[Music]
see him sitting there he's smiling
that's right [__] it's gonna be a
good night
these edibles are [__] [__] listen if
we ain't doing them we ain't talking I'm
tellin ya we see the devil here on a
daily if we ain't doing you a little
Jumoke edibles Kiske and they weren't
the [__] aggravation what I do an
edible this like substitute heroin I'm
gonna go that deep into the murky waters
for the underworld that's too large a
movie I was gonna get 500 the only have
four left
you're lucky I was gonna get five of
these we will go for 500 milligrams
tonight [__] it
when listen why start October off on the
wrong foot and what I gotta start off
[__] feet how we're gonna [__]
take you guys over the edge you think
I'm one of these other fluffy at
okey-doke calmly yeah we get high you
don't see nothing here we are [__]
in the murky waters look at me go
[Music]
and my friend oh yeah baby around
there you go [__] oh [__]
people running cause they're scared
you don't we thought I've been home all
day I landed at 7:30 this morning I
didn't get no sleep last night I hung
out with the baby I had some spaghetti I
got stoned I made a [__] wedding for
the doctor I could do blood tests on
what's going on but enough with that
[__]
it's bunk hit the [__] Jerry's kids
[Music]
it's time to see how the hablo teacher
calmly store tomorrow I sold that in the
belly room
I'll see you [__] in Columbus
this winter
[Music]
alright [__] damn it's bonking
time if you got him sparking with not go
sit next to mom she'll give me the
comfort that you need
you think we're [__] around on him
listen if you're watching this if you're
Nadine get off right now [__] I
don't want you doing bong hits and
failing [__] algebra we're smoking
some tremendous weed as usual you know
what a little [__] Skywalker from
perennial this [__] hours from
perennial show vo container Jeep showing
that [__] Taylor that Lisa that's gun
even least Mac and [__] death these
days look at them with an eight a
[__] presidential from Sunset herbal
same place where you get these Khushi's
same place where you get the stars of
[__] debt North Hollywood Burbank
Boulevard
once you see Denny's keep going oh [__]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you see why it's good to have a hook
gets a nose get around you see that you
didn't think you could [__] see they
won laughs a big nose for uncle Joey I
don't need it all I do is smoke parts
nah nah nah nah
you can move [__] around [__]
[Music]
Lee is going down
without warning the wizard walks by oh
[__] just keeps walking oh [__] Lee
taking it to the hoop tonight training
[__] we're going back to basic
training get that bong ready get that
[__] big bamboo ready get that gas
mask ready whatever the [__] you got
tonight we're going to eat that's it
please plant up on the right don't ever
smoke boy [__] yeah they used to sell
them I connected to a bar a little gas
less that goes in your face
[Music]
what that concept is are you guys doing
all right
oopsie cool side I love you guys thank
you for [__] tuning in with us on
Mondays and Wednesdays the bike leans a
beat the [__] Giants I love it
[__] the [__] Monday Night Football
you got uncle Joey and your little
[__] Godfather lee-sia
the body of Christ we're going be put it
I gotta get you into that 400 range in
the right you know why he's been
training [__] I got em under the
regiment of Dec this how a training is
good at 79 there's a training day [__]
without
[Music]
we both do you ate some ass huh it's a
mess you don't want them to mix a siness
mix like singing a young explosion and
about Justine
[Music]
now it's time for brief anumber to
people what else you guys doing yourself
on a Monday night huh
uncle Joey's here bringing you love
knowledge [__] anything you need you
know I love you mother [__] well here
for you [__] just playing some
music and relax them when I was [__]
sixty or eighteen this is what I'd be
doing on a Monday night with your
friends hanging out and you know a
little early they go behind the wall of
[__] sleep
this is black zombies first [__] out
right here just in case you don't know
now you know [__]
[Music]
yummy for your tummy [__] screwing
into my mind right now
oh [__]
[Music]
well
are you kidding me and you won't listen
to what Justin Timberlake what I'm
giving you right here
[Music]
oh [__] tremendous that's it and that's
that [__] you know eight bong
hits later what eight or nine eight four
hundred milligrams a light dinner [__]
happens
it's just going to be moving quickly
tonight on this [__] show
[Music]
dr. police down [__] straight
from the [__] the diaphragm
[Music]
there we go [__] I like to
spend this little time with you guys
believe I like spending this time with
you the most [__] people in this
neighborhood how's that me you don't
bother me we get together we send smoke
signals at each other this is what life
is truly about if you think about it
it's not about the [__] shootings and
this and that if everybody did what we
were doing right now we had no problems
and I've been doing this since day one
this is my favorite [__] activities
the sophomore year in high school inside
yeah - staring at the [__] Flag
understand me
[Music]
hey you can't see nobody gets their
feelings hurt and everybody's home early
that's it in nineteen and this all idea
with my main man of Zillow and the shad
of death there's way this is the real
feel yeah this is the real feeling
this is Skywalker that got that [__]
larynx going [__] I'm telling you
we got the match of debt tonight ten
seconds
[Music]
yes strong with the [__] become
filled with you this [__] fine Apple
expressly that all these get oh my god
the [__] out of here I don't want to
brief around me let's just knock it over
all the [__] well I do a bomb and
watch me I want to be hit like John
Jones punching in the [__] face if
not why you gotta get what I want to see
the devil for when I see the devil I sit
there get the notebook you [__] around
you just like by yourself
[Music]
classic [__] out I forget about it
all the time my [__] mind and that
[__] that's out there now thank God for
guns and roses trying to Satan bad
company that's the bond with it there
you go
oh [__] there you go that's the one
that's the one that killed Kennedy oh
[__] - oh yeah together with you people
a night like this
loosens me up loosens you up and now
everybody's tip-top Michael don't forget
it's [__] Monday Rosh Hashanah Monday
you gotta come out the gate I could you
on fire you understand me
you don't give a [__] take a twenty rub
it between your hands and put it in your
[__] pocket and make a mental note so
you always have between your pocket this
year that's how the [__] thats right
sure not so Bach but if you think small
you're gonna be small you put a dollar
in your pocket half dollars you put it
one in your pocket and twenties you put
two youngsters in your pocket tonight
say a prayer say God I'll change [__]
everything keep my [__] cockpit
[__] back like this all year watch
what happens I'm saying [__] you think
you're dealing with it we're talking
about reefer what's up my edibles we'll
talk about Black Sabbath and we're
talking about Jewish history
Shabbat some I shall not survive [__]
understand me and if you really wanna
have good dreams take a [__] lunge it
on the bill and blunt your [__]
forehead and go to sleep that's how old
you sleep don't even put on goggles they
just put a yardstick on their [__]
thing you think I'm [__] with you
trust me I grew up with these people
they're savages yeah you gotta think big
- big big [__] I'm going to feed
one more bonding and we'll shut the
light will let you get the teddy bear
and dream about uncle Joey in the whole
[__] deal cuz if you've been watching
this you're gonna have nightmares
tonight and I'm gonna be in and put a
bomb chasing you with a [__] lighter
[Music]
no [__] one the Pipers clock anyway I
love you [__] we'll be back in
ten minutes
thank you for [__] sharing this look
bondage with us and our little [__] up
moment day you know which is human you
like to burn off some energy and this is
it but the [__] you want me to sit here
tell you this is not right through this
way - I don't give a [__] I'm an old fat
[__] loser I love all this [__] what
I'm gonna do be it Starbucks at some bar
right now jumping up and down get the
[__] out of here
stay black we'll be back in 10 minutes
youtube.com / c / what Joey Diaz
we love you [__] eight don't
let them stop you get out there tomorrow
more than dicksmack all of them you
understand me just take that dick and
pound them in the head like a [__]
white cop hitting the black [__]
victim with a [__] baton stick and
that's it I love you [__] stay
black we'll see you in 10 minutes
I got weave every to it between my
fingers I love it